Craig is with us in Los Angeles
Craig no no the Dave Ramsey show hello
Dave hi so tell me your story what is
your net worth sir oh boy I got my last
calculations about 1.7 million okay not
including that cool what's that oh wow
how much is the house oh it's five
hundred on the low end
okay so 2.2 roughly yeah anyway okay
and what's it invested in oh boy I got
investments all over the place we got a
lot of mutual funds I have some land and
an annuity and just mainly mutual funds
how old are you guys
I'm sixty-one my wife is 70 okay how did
you do this did you inherit the money no
no no no no no it's not about oh boy
saving coins when my mother gave me a
coin Bank when I was a little tyke
mm-hmm I've been saving saving saving
mm-hmm what's your average income so
your working lifetime oh boy average
probably right now it's about it's about
60 so have average kind of rough to
figure out what's the most I ever maybe
for you what's the most you ever made
probably about 60 65 never made more
than 65,000 you have 2.2 million dollar
net worth that's 61 years old
that's pretty impressed yeah well my
wife contribute a lot to that also so
she was I'm talking about household
income
oh the helpful together together at one
point we were about 130,000 a year that
was nine ten years ago gotcha okay all
right that's what I was looking for so
how did that you started investing and
saving and you've been a natural saver
how many new cars have you bought I
bought a dealer demo once about 20 years
ago one okay and that guy that got
wrecked so I had to buy another car just
yeah just six months ago
so that was kind of disappointing
because I was I'd like my Cadillac of
minivans I've striving my Pontiac I
liked that band and somebody ran a red
light and took off the front end of that
thing so I had to go buy another car oh
yeah talk about giving what part is it
played in the process giving is just
nominal it hasn't been a super part of
the process you know it dude church and
family and it's just basic givings you
graduate from college next day I just
got a an associate degree when I was
about 55 years old what did you do for a
living I'm a quality manager at a
metrology laboratory Wow we were a great
example of a great American success
story
congratulations sir Wow thank you for
joining us